how did they talk around well it was an  unusual choice definitely I had a number  of different sort of opportunities and  for one thing the risk was very  appealing it's a very compelling  screenplay written by a guy named Chris  Terrio who who wrote Argo which was a  movie that I directed and I really liked  what Henry had done with and Amy had  done in Man of Steel and I really liked  the the version of the Batman that they  were doing which was you know the sort  of Zach came to me and said you know I  want you to do this Batman and I said I  don't think I'm really right for this  you know this the young guy who was  avenging his parents death and goes and  puts on a cowl and fights supervillains  maybe you know at one time but he said  no no that's not it he's completely  broken down he's older he's falling  apart thirds of the moral bankruptcy